bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week-end de ce
vendredi 30 octobre tout de suite le
sommaire de cette émission
bastien chauvette en plateau pour nous
parler de la soirée spéciale halloween
samedi 31 octobre organisée à l'espace
decaux villes de voisins-le-bretonneux
par son association soudja association
qui vous initie au théâtre et au cinéma
25 août au responsable des événements de
l'île des loisirs attraper le parlera de
l'événement à crown heights jean bernard
et hier président de l'association vivre
au village de magny les hameaux nous
présente la soirée cabaret avec le
spectacle de la troupe proxem organisé
pour la bonne cause
samedi 31 octobre à 20h30 barbara ne
majeur exposants au salon de l'auto
n'est arcisienne nous présente le
concept nouveau qui se tiendra à bois
d'arcy samedi 31 octobre de 10h de 10h à
18h30 partez à la rencontre des
commerçants et artisans arcisien alors
avant de saluer nos invités je vous
propose de découvrir l'exposition du
château de versailles dans le cadre du
tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv
vous pourrez ainsi profiter de cette
exposition le roi mort jusqu'au 21
février 2016 draperies noir tapisserie
façon brocard reconstitution du grand
cénotaphe et jeux de lumière une
scénographie baroque exceptionnelle pour
la nouvelle exposition au château de
versailles
le roi est mort cette exposition accorde
à la scénographie une place toute
particulière parce que elle est tout à
fait dans l'esprit de ce que c'était
car toute la cérémonie les cérémonies
funèbres de louis xiv ont été organisées
par l'administration des menus plaisirs
et c'était des décors éphémères des
costumes éphémère tout était fait pour
la cérémonie pour ce temps de deuil
cette exposition permet de mettre en
lumière la mort de louis xiv survenu le
1er septembre 1715 mettant fin au plus
long règne de la monarchie française de
l'autopsié aux funérailles du roi soleil
en passant par l'étiquette du deuil est
la cour tout le protocole y est détaillé
dans les règles des deuils étaient les
suivantes une couleur la plupart du
temps c'est le noir
c'est qui est plus important c'est la
nature des vêtements c'est tout ceci est
très codifié et notamment la longueur
par exemple la longueur du manteau c'est
les attributs comporte les épées les
livres que l'on tient à la main les
éventails les coiffures les bijoux tous
ces détails dépend de deux choses
ça dépend de la personne pour qui en
porte le deuil et ça dépend de la
personne qui porte le deuil la mort du
roi soleil marquent la fin de 72 ans
d'absolutisme royal et offre la
possibilité aux idées nouvelles du
siècle des lumières de se développer
les premiers pamphlet vont faire leur
apparition la mort de louis xiv c'est là
le début de la chute des jésuites en
france et c'est important c'est la fin
d'un gouvernement personnel est très
autoritaire plus de latitudes plus de
tolérance plus de possibilités dans le
domaine de l'édition et de la presse
il sera possible de profiter de cette
exposition très riche en informations au
château de versailles jusqu'au 21
février 2016
nous commençons cette émission avec une
programmation spéciale halloween avec
bastian chauvet président de
l'association soudja à voisins le
bretonneux bonsoir et vincent couteau
responsable des événements l'île de
loisirs de trappes bonsoir alors
messieurs vous nous avez concocté une
programmation un peu spéciale on va
commencer avec vous bastien samedi soir
à l'espace de covile qu'est ce qui nous
attend alors oui nous avons la deuxième
édition de la soirée fait moins peur
qu'un festival donc c'est la deuxième
année qu'on le fait maintenant
l'idée c'est de rassembler un petit peu
plein de choses de la culture sur site
pour faire une manifestation familiale
parce qu'on est un petit peu entre la
sortie des vacances et noël donc c'est
finalement cette soirée d'halloween elle
se présente bien elle se présente bien
avec les activités de l'association
puisqu'elle a dû théâtre de la
scénographie donc c'est tout ce qui est
son et lumière et du cinéma
on va s'appuyer sur tout un tissu local
où il y aura également des contes des
spectacles de magie
donc la soirée les diviser en deux
parties une première partie activité
avec des dérivés de jeux forains ou là
on est là c'est vraiment votre
association qui va c'est vraiment notre
association qui anime exactement avec
tout un bestiaire donc on va pouvoir
affronter dans leur défi une pirate
maudite un dynamiteur foule docteur
frankenstein loup garou et c'est pour
essayer de gagner des bonbons pour le
plus jeune
il y aura également un escape game dont
les inscriptions
sont complètes voilà où là l'idée c'est
de rentrer dans l'antre de jack
o'lantern d'en apprendre un peu plus sur
l'origine de la fête d'halloween est
d'arriver à sortir vivant de cet antre
en résolvant les différentes énigmes et
puis ensuite il y aura également des
autres d'autres associations qui vont
participer l'association garde-fous qui
présentera des comptes dans une tente
complètement dans le noir avec des
lampes torches
voilà on va un peu raconté à se faire
peur l'association 78 tours il fera des
spectacles de magie le club photo qui
pourra photographier les gens en costume
et un son de maquillage etc et ensuite
on aura la deuxième partie de soirée qui
sera fait dès que du cinéma ou la sous
chapiteau il y aura deux films de
projeter autres l hôtel pardon
transylvania suivi de shaun of the dead
d'un film d'humour anglais horrifique et
est ce que justement parmi les ateliers
que votre association va animer y aura
un atelier citrouille comment faire sa
lanterne
il n'ya pas d'atelier citrouille comment
faire ça long terme or c'est pourtant un
grand classique ou un grand classique
après leur visite un petit peu parce
qu'il y aura certes des lanternes
découper y aura des lanternes projeté
aussi puisqu'on a tout un parcours son
et lumière scénographie donc avec des
projections sur monument
et également des projections notamment
sur des citrouilles les visages sont
animées voilà bien dans ce cas je vous
propose de découvrir ensemble comment
sculpter sa citrouille un sujet de
famille bourdillon et camille lambert
ici pas besoin de baguette magique mais
dans un bon couteau à la ferme
pédagogique de l'île des loisirs ces
ateliers citrouille
aujourd'hui une quinzaine d'enfants
s'applique à sculpter leur propre
lanternes
moi j'aime bien que les enfants puissent
décider eux-mêmes ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire un peu quand même qui est cet
esprit ludique
donc du coup les enfants vont dessiner
sur la citrouille tout ce qu'ils veulent
enlever et du coup on va plutôt confier
les parents les aux parents les couteau
et l'a ensuite on va découper dessinée
creuser et découpé réaliser sa lanterne
un travail plus physique n'y paraît
après l'effort le réconfort
la chaire de la citrouille est récupérée
pour une soupe maison une manière aussi
de faire aimer les légumes aux enfants
ça leur fait découvrir les graines qui
peuvent replantés après la chair qui
vont manger ensuite certains enfants
n'aiment pas la soupe de citrouille mais
là d'un seul coup ils vont l'aimer
donc c'est tout bénéfice et puis c'est
convivial salle attitrée elle l est
c'était une fille et elle a des deux
yeux en forme de triangle et
ll bush ils sont riches
j'ai creusé avec un couteau et j'ai
dessiné des uns peut désormais les des
polonais voilà une fois la lanterne
terminé il ne reste plus qu alex ferrer
alors on va continuer cette
programmation spéciale halloween avec
vous vincent plus tôt c'est une soirée à
crown heights que vous me réservez ce
soir déguisements maquillages
racontez nous tout à fait le concept
déjà d'accrobranche de nuit peut
paraître assez assez original on a
développé ce ces événements a depuis
depuis deux ans et donc ce soir c'est la
soirée accro à crown heights halloween
donc on aura du maquillage
phosphorescent ont fourni une lampe
frontale aux participants et puis voilà
tous types de maquillage peut être
réalisé et vous inviter les participants
à venir déguisés exagère alors juste
pour repréciser la crown heights en fait
c'est de l'accrobranche ça monte jusqu'à
15 16 mètres de haut ouais 16 mètres de
haut pour le plus au parcours avec donc
il y aura accès à tous les parcours ce
soir on fournit le maquillage
on a nos opérateurs qui sont là pour
animer avec une petite musique
d'ambiance spéciale pour la soirée
là il reste encore une quinzaine de
places disponibles donc n'hésitez pas et
donc ses 156 mètres de parcours avec une
tyrolienne qui fait pour la fête la plus
grande tyrolienne 456 m là plusieurs
kilomètres de parcours ghana quatre au
total donc est vraiment il y en a pour
tous les goûts du plus bas au plus haut
très bien donc ce soir vendredi 30
octobre à crown heights à partir de 21h
exactement accueille à 20 heures et
début des parties à 21 heures donc on
pourra retrouver toutes les informations
sur votre site
le site de la base de loisirs tout à
fait vous tapez il de loisirs saint
quentin en yvelines et il ya toute une
rubrique événements et actualités sans
qu'elle vous retrouvez toute la
programmation
alors on continue toujours il y aura des
ateliers
si vous parliez d'une cinématique
bastien chauvet à l'espace culturel
decauville et samedi soir des ateliers
cinéma en fait qui forment vos
classiques d'ateliers avec les ateliers
théâtre
en fait il n'y a pas d' ateliers cinéma
sur le site en lui-même ça c'est quelque
chose que nous on fait au sein de
l'association puisque est aussi bien
d'aider des troupes de théâtre que des
ateliers cinéma on va réaliser des
courts métrages tout au long de l'année
par contre tout ça après me comme dire
mis en avant à cette soirée là puisque
l'idée de cette soirée d'halloween c'est
de participer avec d'autres associations
et d'autres entreprises capoue seven que
j'ai pas citer par exemple qui s'occupe
de l'escabeau m mais aussi d'aller
récupérer les comédiens de l'aso qui
vont pouvoir mettre ça en scène tous les
films voilà qu'est vous qui sont
projetés bon évidemment pas hôtel
transylvania shenzhen mais je veux dire
tous les films qui sont projetés sur la
scénographie sont des films qui ont été
réalisés dans le cadre de l'association
donc c'est après c'est vraiment le
travail qui vous jour le jour de
l'association mais du coup tout est dans
cette thématique parce que l'idée c'est
de rester dans un vestiaire connu qui
est qui est un peu celui des films de
universal et warner des années 40 la ou
halloween est devenue la fête qu'on
connaît est passé de la fête celte de sa
main à la fête qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
et tout sera s'explique tout cela sera
expliqué demain d'ailleurs dans des
petits encarts très pédagogique d'accord
vincent couteau créer un court métrage
dans les airs pourquoi pas vous y pensez
et ben pourquoi pas en tout cas on est
prêt à accueillir l'association sans
problème
pour venir filmer dans les différents
environnements de liste de loisirs alors
pour rester maintenant toujours dans
notre rubrique cinéma je prouve je vous
propose le coup de coeur de notre
professionnel lui beaucamp dû signer
cette d'elancourt qui vous donne son
avis sur les films à l'affiché cette
semaine mon coup de coeur cette semaine
cinq longueurs du ciné 7 c'est le
dernier film de ridley scott
alors ridley scott s'est pas si jamais
mauvais mais c'est pas toujours
extraordinaire je pense à prometheus où
l'avant-dernier film mais celui-là il
réussit s'appelle seul sur mars avec
matt damon à l'affiché vais pas vous
raconter l'histoire ça dure deux ans 24
c'est un film qui a été tourné
véritablement en 3d donc il faut essayer
de le voir en 3d on peut aussi voir en
2d mais c'est vrai 3d je tiens à
préciser
et donc c'est sur nos écrans à partir de
mercredi
et puis un deuxième petit coup de coeur
quand même pour julie delpy que j'aime
beaucoup parce que elle sort un film à
une comédie avec dany boon auquel se
rapproche un petit peu du grand public
qui s'appelle lolo et qui est très
réussie avec aussi karine viard donc on
a aussi en sortie nationale
aujourd'hui aussi les sept lots à mon
fils c'est le lot jean rené très content
de vous rencontrer jean monnet alors
après avoir recueilli cet avis de
professionnels nous avons cherché à
savoir ce que vous pensiez des
nouveautés vous aviez au micro de
camille lambert
oui chez mais tu beaucoup aimé qui a vu
le sat enfin voila je crois avant tout
ça donc oui c'était un moment donné
c'était vraiment très intense
par rapport à ce que j'ai vu d'amenabar
c'est pas celui que je préfère mais
bien c'est du bon mot divertissement et
non suspense un très très beau film très
belle histoire l'histoire d'une passion
ça vous prend même quand on a le vertige
on y va on est pris par cette histoire
merveilleux c'était très bien c'était
très bien joué il ya rigolo s'est bien
marré dany boon est atteint un très bon
artiste mais c'est vrai que quand on
fait un rapport avec les ch'tis on est
un petit peu un petit peu déçu quand on
voit ces films comme ça on ceci dit ce
sont des très bons acteurs
c'est comme dit madame un peu loufoque
la seule option à chaud ça très bien
c'est déjanté c'est surtout en échange
d'une heure avec lync farrell en anglais
aussi impeccable j'ai été agréablement
surprise mais c'est free mais d'une
certaine façon c'est pour un certain
public
mais c'est amer quand même si ça fait du
bien de voir qu'une farrell
dans un rôle comme savait si retour sur
nantes au plateau du 7-8 week-end avec
une première partie consacrée à la
programmation d'alwyn donc je rappelle
que vous pourrez vous rendra à lille de
loisirs ce soir vendredi 30 octobre à
partir de 20 heures
vous êtes attendus par toute l'équipe de
vincent couteau pour un parcours à crown
heights venez déguisés et vous serez
maquillée de demain soir samedi 31
octobre à partir de 18 heures rendez
vous à l'espace culturel decauville pour
une programmation spéciale halloween
au programme ateliers et cinématiques
place maintenant à notre deuxième invité
jean jean bernard et hier bonsoir vous
êtes le président de l'association vivre
au village ce que vous pourriez nous
dire un mot sur l'objet de votre
association
c'est une association à but humanitaire
qui travaille sur un petit village
s'appelle tamalous au coeur du cameroun
cette association aide les gens à
trouver un
un développement rural pour avoir un
avenir perspectives d'avenir
donc nous travaillons sur les enfants
avec le ned la porter à deux écoles
nous travaillons aussi sur le plan
sanitaire avec
lutte contre le paludisme pourrait aussi
améliorer l'hygiène le combattre les
vers intestinaux par exemple et j'ai
toutes les maladies qui se développe
dans dans les pays tropicaux et pour
financer tous ces projets vous organisés
chaque année une soirée pour recueillir
des fonds et cette année vous avez
choisi une soirée sur le thème du
cabaret askin raison spéciale à cette
fois et c'est simplement parce que l'une
de nos adhérents peu sa fille et
comédienne dans une petite troupe qui
s'appelle troc scène qu'il est basée la
ville juifs et ils nous ont donné leur
accord pour animer une autre soirée donc
c'est une soirée tamarelle avec surtout
tournés sur loana dérision le rire
sourire avec des chansons qui
n'aboutissent jamais un soupçon de magie
dans un monde mystique
voilà c'est un cadre e année mais dans
le monde dans la soirée qui est une une
fête franco camerounaise avec un dîner
camerounais et après toute une partie
festive danse basé sur la musique
africaine
alors avant de détailler davantage cette
soirée je vous propose de découvrir un
extrait du spectacle cabaret de la
troupe tranxène de villejuif amont
signalé seulement à mon signal
vous replacerait dans la même position
que non plus
où
je vous demande de lever cette personne
jean-bernard hier vous attendez donc à
partir de 20h30 samedi soir les gens
pour votre soirée à l'estaminet de magny
les hameaux
donc vous étiez en train de décrire
qu'il y aurait un repas camerounais le
spectacle de la troupe troxel quels sont
les autres temps forts à les couvrir
déjà c'est toute cette soirée est
organisée pour pouvoir trouver des fonds
puisque le dans le projet actuel qui a
commencé c'est le forage d'un puits en
eau potable autour du centre économique
et socioculturel que nous avons
construit depuis 2010 est-ce que vous
avez monté une exposition justement
tombé sur un os avec tous les thèmes de
de l'association tout le tout
tous les concepts d'avenir et surtout le
lait donner des perspectives aux
habitants pour pouvoir vivre sur place
c'est aussi une façon de lutter contre
finalement la migration des gens qui
n'ont pas de perspective pour pour se
développer pour vivre dont qu'ils
essayent d'aller ailleurs pour pouvoir
au moins survivre là on leur donne les
moyens de de se développer donc pour
tous les jeunes d'avoir une perspective
d'avenir en particulier par le biais de
de développement 2 à kloten
principalement dans la fonte d'une
cacaoyère on a une palme une passion al
murray une citronneraie tout ça ça donne
des perspectives d'avenir et les jeunes
préfèrent rester dans leur village
malgré les conditions difficiles
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'eau
ni l'électricité dans ce village où nous
intervenons donc mais ça leur donne
quand même des perspectives et il
souhaite rester et avec elle il faut
apporter de l'aide et là nous
construisons un puits dans les projets à
venir
c'est trouver des moyens de l'énergie en
particulier par l'installation de
panneaux solaires pour mener à bien tous
ses projets vous avez besoin que les
gens soient nombreux à venir alors de
votre soirée à l'estaminet de magny les
hameaux
samedi soir à partir de 20h30 jean
bernard et hier merci d'avoir été sur
notre plateau aujourd'hui nous
poursuivons notre émission avec barbara
ne mager exposantes au salon de
l'automne de bois d'arcy qui lance la
première édition samedi 31 octobre de
10h à 18h 30 bonsoir bonsoir
alors je dis première édition mais c'est
pas tout à fait ça parce que il y avait
le festival art si féminin qui s'est
déroulé au printemps dernier le salon de
l'automne en fait s'inspire fortement de
ce festival art si féminin s'inspire un
petit peu parce que finalement rssi
féminin c'était c'est un salon dédié à
la femme dont les exposantes son dvd i
vendeuse à domicile indépendante et donc
c'est un noyau de huit femmes qui ont eu
l'idée est qu'ils ont soumises à la
mairie donc la mairie a été enthousiasmé
par l'idée est donc on a lancé arcis
féminin oui donc dédié à la femme l'a
donc demain il y aura le salon de
l'automne donc il y aura bien ce noyau
de huit femmes effectivement de huy huit
exposants pardon si féminin était un
franc succès oui tout à fait donc que
décidé de reconduire une autre exact
initiative peut-être en élargissant un
petit peu ça sent tout à fait là il n'y
aura pas que dvd y aura des auto
entrepreneurs des artisans pas
exclusivement de wallers y met de bois
d'arcy et des environs donc il y aura
du scrapbooking il y aura le
scrapbooking pour qu'on comprenne bien
qu'est ce que c'est alors c'est un
atelier qui le principe on part de rien
on va dire ou de produits comme j'ai vu
par exemple une boîte à pizza devenir
quelque chose réellement de magnifiques
c'est vraiment de là c'est fait c'est
fait à la main avec toute la passion est
là justement il y aura un atelier
scrapbooking découvert que les gens
pourront s'essayer à ces ateliers
il y aura également des bougies il y
aura de la mosaïque
il y aura également pour les plus
gourmands des gaufres en fait sur place
il y aura également donc du bien n'est
des produits de bien-être à base d'aloe
vera
il y aura des bijoux en argent salon de
l'automne c'est vraiment fait la réunion
d'artisans et de commerçants qui
viennent exposer leur savoir faire
alors vous on pourra vous retrouvez donc
derrière votre sang vous serez présent
et qu'est-ce que vous aurez à nous
proposer
alors moi j'aurai à proposer donc des
produits de bien-être à base d'aloe vera
donc début vap parce que cette plante
est reconnue pour ses bienfaits
mais beaucoup plus pour la peau beaucoup
plus pour les cheveux par exemple parce
qu'effectivement cette plante
elle est donc riche de vingt vitamines
20 acides aminés 12 minéraux donc elle
régénère la peau mais les gens
connaissent mois les bienfaits en
interne c'est à dire en buvable c'est un
jus de légumes à la base et qui a des
pouvoirs détoxifiant qui booste les
défenses immunitaires
donc je vais mettre en avant en fait
tout s'est tous ces bienfaits là qui
sont méconnus encore du public
est ce que c'est un temps fort
particulier ce salon de l'automne à ne
pas rater ou à ce que les gens peuvent
librement venir sur toute la journée de
10h à 12h30 librement oui toute la
journée de 10h à 18h30 donc à la salle
de la ferme de la tramblais haut
oui rue du avenue du parc pardon donc il
y aura des temps forts on va dire tout
au long de la journée très clairement
des ateliers qui sont pas pré programmés
on en aura un peu tout au long de la
journée voilà alors barbares ne mâchait
remercie d'être venus aujourd'hui sur
notre plateau je rappelle donc que nous
pourrons retrouver barbara le majeur à
son stand d'exposition à la salle des
fêtes de bois d'arcy pour le salon de
l'automne samedi 31 octobre de 10h à
18h30
je vous propose maintenant comme chaque
semaine de passer à notre rubrique
littérature découvrons ensemble la
sélection café pour vous le pavé du
canal
le tome 1 de lazarus intitulé pour la
famille de roeck à l'arc et arcas est le
premier tome d'une série de comics qui
ont connu un grand succès aux états unis
on est dans un futur proche la planète a
connu une immense crise économique et
sociale
les frontières ne sont plus politiques
ou géographiques mais elles sont créées
en fonction de la richesse de certaines
familles il ya un système féodal qui a
été instaurée donc il y à la famille qui
évidemment au dessus de tout le monde
puis les serres et enfin ceux qu'on
qualifie de déchets donc c'est ce qu'ils
ne servent absolument pas aux familles
qui est une population qui ne fait que
leur coûter et qu'il faut nourrir
malgré eux dans ce système de famille
chaque famille à ce qu'on appelle un
lazare le hasard est une est un humain
qui a été créée exprès pour le combat
donc on va suivre dans la série lazarus
le lazare de la famille carlyle qui est
une des familles les plus puissantes de
la planète et cela zaers est une jeune
femme qui s'appelle eve qui est persuadé
d'être la fille de chair et de sang de
son père et de sa mère et qui a été créé
génétiquement et qui est là pour
défendre les intérêts de sa famille donc
c'est assez violent
mais c'est un scénario assez classique
finalement un système féodal une guerre
fratricide une créature qui se posent
des questions sur ses sentiments ça la
raison qu'elle a d'être sur terre et
c'est une bonne série
le deuxième tome est déjà sorti il est
aussi bien dans chaque tome on nous tend
un peu des pistes à découvrir et puis on
n'a pas forcément la résolution
immédiate mais on espère que dans le
troisième tome ce sera le cas et ainsi
de suite
et je rappelle que dans le cadre du
concours photo organisé par tv fil 78 en
partenariat avec lui vers 16h l'union
nationale 16 des photographes du
sud-ouest de l'île de france
vous êtes invités à envoyer vos plus
beaux clichés sur le thème votre regard
sur votre ville avant le 20 novembre à
la fiche à l'adresse pardon qui
s'affiche à l'écran
alors avant de se quitter je vous
propose quelques sorties spéciales
halloween pour ce week end
découvrez les parcours acrobatiques dans
les arbres de nuit vendredi 30 octobre à
21h à lille de loisirs avec à crown
heights en voulez-vous jusqu'à 16 mètres
de hauteur pour franchir les nombreux
obstacles des parcours et des vallées
des tyroliennes mesurant jusqu'à 156 m
l'activité démarre par un atelier de
maquillage phosphorescent et pour que la
fête soit parfaite venez déguisés le
costume le plus inattendu se verra
récompensé passons maintenant au château
de rambouillet avec un retour à l'école
ou oui mais pas n'importe quelle école
l'école des sorciers un moment unique à
ne pas louper au château de rambouillet
vendredi 30 et samedi 31 octobre à
partir de 10h pour se familiariser à la
sorcellerie et sortilèges en tout genre
pour les petits quant aux plus grands
aussi ont le droit à leur lot de
surprises
un mystère à résoudre des indices à
déchiffrer des disparitions suspectes ce
sera à eux de mener l enquête
c'est la fin de ce sept huit week-ends
émission à voir et à revoir sur notre
site internet
je vous souhaite un excellent week end